I have video for you today of a long time.
Trump Brown nosing sycophant, one of the real
sick Fox news,
Trump defenders realizing on live television
that Trump is absolutely clueless and has
no idea what he's doing. And you can actually
see him become more and more enraged despite
being someone who is almost exclusively wrong
on policy. I'm talking of course of Brian
Kilmeade, the one that some people think is
the dumb one on Fox and friends. Uh, but it
may not actually be the case. And of course
there is a lot of competition for that role.
Uh, that designation on Fox and friends. We've
been talking about Donald Trump's recent decision
to pull back troops in Northern Syria to allow
Turkey to run a military operation along with
Donald Trump's threat to destroy and obliterate
Turkey's economy if they do anything Donald
Trump doesn't like, combined with within hours
Turkey bombing Kurdish forces in Northern
Syria. We've already talked about all of that.
Brian Kilmeade came up with one of the reasons
why Donald Trump's actions are concerning,
which is yes, they endanger the Kurds in Northern
Syria, which happens to be a concern that
a lot of people share.
It's Noam Chomsky who shares that concern.
It's me. It's some Republicans as well. And
you can just tell that Brian Kilmeade is disgusted
with Trump in this video. And you can also
tell when you go to the wide shot or I think
it's a wide shot the entire time when you
see Steve deuce. Do see, I always have to
be careful to to pronounce it correctly. When
you see cohost Steve Doocy and I believe it's
Ainslie Earhart, they don't want anything
to do with this. They are still fully on the
sucking up to Trump train. And what's funny
is that Brian Kilmeade, if you watch him deliver
any political opinion, he always has like
a slightly confused expression on his face.
Even if he's making a roundabout point that
has some element of truth, which he does in
this case, he always seems like one microsecond
away from completely losing the thread and
becoming totally Incan here incoherent. And
meanwhile, Steve Doocy looks visibly uncomfortable
with what? Kill me to saying, Ainslie Earhart
seems to want no part in the conversation
one way or another. Take a look at this.
Here's what a disaster, I mean the president's
statement through Stephanie Grisham is, you
know, we defeated the, the cafe, the health
is destroyed. We would not have done that
without the Kurds who did all of our fighting
while our guys, the reason why our casualties
were so low is because courage did all the
fighting. Now we're saying, okay, Turks go
wipe them out or forced them out. What kind
of messages that to the next ally that wants
to side with us, meanwhile would taking Sunni
prisoners and giving him to Sunni Turkey who's
been nothing but irresponsible though technically
a NATO ally, a disastrous series of events.
I hope the prison will rethink this. I think
the president is doing exactly what he's wants
to because he has made from the get go very
clear to release ISIS campaign.
Promise to end a war country and abandon our
allies. Man. Steve Doocy as a guy to play
off of is just tough, right? I mean he sounds
like a little kid. He's a 62 year old man,
but he sounds like a kid. Well, I think Trump
is just doing what he wants to. So yeah. And
then that riles up kill Mead even more as
we continue. That's a campaign promise I ended
in the people that got the caliphate destroyed.
I think when people find out that somebody
else is willing to take over the fight against
ISIS, they're going to be okay. I'm just taking
it. Well, Turkey, Turkey second to fight ISIS.
We have given Turkey permission to do that
and to take, and the quote was, Turkey will
now be responsible for all ISIS fighters and
killed and wipe out the Kurds. Are you kidding
me?
Again, we're bending our most loyal allies
who did all our fighters. All we did is armed
them and they did all the work and now we
say, good luck. Good luck surviving. Well,
it looks like that's the TAC, the white house
and the president's going to take a, we're
going to have as bad as Brian kill Mead's
political analysis is, even though he hits
on something here, of course Steve do sees
dumb comments or just too much. Uh, w w good
luck surviving Brian. That's the tactic the
white house is taking. So there, there are
these tiny little sort of hairline cracks
that are forming in the echo chamber of Fox
news by mere coincidence because Kilmeade
wants soldiers in Syria. Do you think that
after a segment like this, when they go to
commercial or after they're done filming,
do you think they go to the break room, stand
around the water cooler and they say, Brian,
what, what was that all about?
That was weird. What, what was what went on
there? And what you have is okay Brian Kilmeade
like a clock that doesn't move. It ends up
being right twice a day and Brian Kilmeade
has stumbled upon what is at least a partially
correct take and it just seems completely
out of place on Fox news now that that's over.
Fox news can resume the self eating by the
way, which is actually the bigger media story
that I think we should be talking about. I've
been preparing you for this for about a year
now. I think it's been about a year. Certainly
dating back to last may, if not earlier. Um,
when we start looking at the possible separation
of Trump and Fox of Trump and Republicans,
you have to understand that there is much
more to it than simply will Fox support Trump
in the 2020 reelection campaign, we are starting
to see political disagreements that are becoming
more than just public.
They are starting to actually affect the way
that politics is happening behind the scenes
in Washington DC. You're starting to see Moscow,
Mitch separate from Trump a little bit more
than he has in the past over this Syria issue.
You're starting to see loony Lindsey, loony,
Lindsey Graham, start to distance himself
from Trump a little bit, even though he was
like the greatest Trump Brown nose are out
there for a very long period of time. But
it's not just forward progress because then
Trump will back pedal and he'll pull some
people back in. But then it'll happen again
and we'll see what ultimately happens. I don't
know if you said to me today, David, take
a position by November of 2020, will Trump
and Fox still have this marriage made? Not
in heaven, but you know, uh, with a prenup
and under duress, which is I guess the way
most of Donald Trump's relationships seem
to develop.
Will we still have that in November of 2020
or will we have seen a total separation between
Trump and Fox news? And if so, that raises
a whole host of additional questions. Will
Trump have moved over to OAN one American
news network, which I've been predicting for
a while and Trump has started to promote a
little bit around the edges. Will we see,
uh, those right wing media outlets that abandoned
Trump actively promote an alternative? Will
they promote a Democrat? I don't think so.
Will they promote a primary challenge to Trump
are voting third party? I don't know. But
these are some of the interesting questions
that I look forward to seeing answered as
the campaign continues to develop, let me
know what you think will ultimately happen.
Let me know what you make. By the way of Brian
Kilmeade, uh, staking out this position, which
again, it's not unique to kill me.
There are lots of Republicans who want troops
in Syria for different reasons. The curd.
Uh, the danger to the Kurds specifically though
is not always the one that you hear.